did i ever tell you that i thought it
was so strange that one day i was
watching tv
and you were on the regis philbin show
you know the regis and kathy lee
and you came on and it was at the height
of smashing pumpkins you guys were you
know
forget about it it was like and you were
really kind of a man of mystery
and all of a sudden regis goes yeah you
know who happens to be a fan of ours is
uh billy corgan and he's here today and
you come
marching out and you're hanging with
regis and i was like this is the most
bizarre booking ever
i you know that was my idea by the way i
called it
you called them and they were probably
like yeah sure we'll have you on i
usually write in the morning so i would
sit on the couch and watch them every
morning
right i think i literally think i wrote
the riff to 1979 you know this riff
watching regis and kathie lee
i swear to god so i called them or you
know i caught somebody
my people call their people and i said
i'd love to come on
and uh it was awesome they were really
sweet but if anybody wants to watch the
clip
she starts hitting on me during the show
live on
live live on the show really some joke
about me having no hair
don't let us shake you up billy i'm here
to protect you believe me
well i know she likes the long-haired
men no no no babe no no
never grows on the playground you're
looking very fine
and i was like wow kathleen's hitting on
me this is amazing
now that i couldn't have anticipated